you
hi everyone is Jerry in 1987 mikhail tal
played a blitz game against anatoly
karpov it was played in Brussels it was
a 30 move encounter wasn't perfect chest
but an interesting game nevertheless
something that's maybe to be expected
when you have contrasting styles tall of
course the tactical wizard Karpov master
of strategy both will look to steer the
game into positions that suit their
style of play so let's see how it plays
out we have tall kicking off with e4
Karpov electing the solid caro-kann
defense with c4 this is going in for an
accelerated pan off attack Center being
liquidated quite a bit and with that
comes an isolated deep on but it
transitions to now a hanging pawn
structure after the capture on c3 going
forward with a king side fiend keto is
black white establishes a pawn in the
center Bishop d3 both sides Castle the
Queen Knight comes out all pieces need
to get working the rook now and a half
open file rook to e8 to facilitate a 5
but with Bishop g5 that's not available
for just a moment and now Bishop to e6
so with this last move what is it
looking to do well these hanging pawns
you need to look to restrict them in
some way and that's its main aim with
maybe Knight to a5 to follow we get to
see none of that however rook takes
Bishop sacrifice what do you get in
return for well the first thing that
cries out is these double pawns to me at
least these double pawns and
additionally these the King side is a
bit more weak this F pawn is no longer
around to watch over the g6 pawn so
these guys right here better stay put
can also view it as white now having the
bishop pair and to be a bit more exact
the LightSquared bishop is the one that
I would give more weight to because it
has no counterpart and if either one of
these pawns move
there is just no repairing the light
squares around this King position
so first order of business is to do what
exactly well it's to hit the weakest
link namely e6 and with these next few
moves we're seeing white just put
pressure on e6 in black having to defend
Queen d6 Queen e2 Knight to d8 there's
not a better way to defend than Knight
to d8 King f7 gets hammered immediately
with Bishop to f4 hits the Queen of
course vacates g5 and the bishops immune
from capture due to a mate in two so
King f7 is just crazy ninety-eight rook
e1 rook to c8 there's well there's still
well it's not needed for black to defend
against east six right here going
forward with these types of captures
well there's just no attack at this
point anymore black is winning so need
to be cautious about getting material
back looking for an attack here keep the
Queen's on the board and instead tuck
the bishop excuse me now tuck the bishop
but rather reroute the knight defends
the bishop and looks to pivot on that
efore Square King gets out of out of
that diagonal very very sensible move
it's out of the pin Knight e4 posts up
hits the Queen Queen c7 keeps pressure
on something the bishop and the pawn
bishop backs up in now e5 some action in
the center but it's something that tal
ignores and plays h4 instead it's pretty
surprising to see this type of move
played with the Queen still on the board
still a lot a lot of pieces on the board
right here but its main aim is to do
what exactly it's to weaken these light
squares trying to induce this Jeep on to
move and then focus eventually on the h7
square one alternative would be to play
d5 that also looks pretty appealing it
boxes out the knight and it really makes
this nice shine on e4 blockading this
pawn on e and well it's just a complete
domino effect isn't it blockades this
pond and
Bishop looks very very silly just
staring at its own pun anyhow it's an
alternative but it's something much more
direct h4 really coming right at black
captures on dh5 no need to just be
recapturing its main aim you have to
follow through you do h4 to play h5 if
you're not going to be able to do both
h4 is a waste of time so G takes H and
this is a serious air what would have
been better is Queen to b6 and if there
is a capture while the Queen comes over
to recapture and she's a very very good
defensive piece actually in black as the
side who's better we don't have that
Queen b6 is not played G takes H was
played and this is a mistake in so too
is White's next move White's next move
was to take on h5 that is not the best
move what is the best move if you'd like
to pause the video see if you can find
the best move for white okay the best
move for white in this position is
Knight f6 exploiting the pin on the
e-file if Bishop takes Knight Bishop
recaptures you have to recapture and
this is convincing enough white is
winning the Queen at the very least so
one quick side line would be well if
you're not taking the night and you're
playing here well Knight takes h7 this
is going to be all the more powerful
when you capture an h5 because now when
the knight moves deadly discovered
checks there's not going to be a good
defense for black in this position we
don't have that taking on h5 was a
mistake and white taking on h5 is a
mistake so it's something typical to see
I don't know what the time situation was
but again it is blitz mistakes are going
to happen rook to f8 getting it off of
that e1 square was being attacked and
now it's at least a bit more active on a
half-open F file Bishop c2 these go hand
in hand h4 h5 you're doing it to weaken
the light squares you're doing it so
that the bishop
then put pressure on at age seven point
Queeny five centralizes herself pins the
bishop pins the night but the night
really isn't pinned it actually moves in
this position with the knight g3 and
white invest some more material to
displace the Queen Queen takes for a
king h2 the Queen is a bit off sides
these this rook on FA actually c8 the
night on d8 not doing a whole lot the
bishop in rook or maybe the only ones
around to defend but it's a difficult
defense to come up with here for black
surprisingly there is a move which will
allow the position to remain equal
that's what the computer will say but
but the two humans play and that's very
very difficult I doubt that this game
would end you know in a peaceful way
what is the move here to be played well
what Karpov tries is h6 and this just
gets crushed
we have Bishop takes pawn there's not
going to be a defense but there is a
defensive move in that of can you see it
the defensive move is Bishop h6 it seems
very weird to put a piece in the way of
our just putting a bishop in a spot
where both the Queen and Bishop would be
taking it but Bishop takes Bishop allows
rook f7 and each seven is being defended
and same thing with Queen takes H rook
f7 yet again and the game continues but
that was not played pawn h6 was played
and again Bishop takes pawn King tries
to run but he's not going he can't go
anywhere Bishop takes Bishop there's
just no defense
what is tried is rook takes f2 but now
that's this is running into a mate and
three tal ends up going forward with a
variation that ends up in a mate and for
with starting with Queen h7 Queen g6 all
very forcing much easier to calculate
when each move comes with the check and
after this final move Bishop h6
discovered check
Karpov ends up resigning King in the
corner take your pick
g7 or h7 that'll be
so an interesting game I hope you
enjoyed it and that's all for this video
take care bye